I've told you how much I've loved these
videos of late right Chris I love
amazing oh my gosh it's so great I can't
like them and retweet them fast enough
it's and and there have been frequent
because it's every time the Cowboys lose
and they lost three in a row here's
Stephen H Smith at work after the the
Cowboys lost the Jets rolling oh my gosh
and of course the tomorrow was first
take that airs every single weekday
10:00 a.m. the noon eastern on ESPN he
is Stephen a Smith
that is just virtuoso material they just
won't let you down walk me through it so
you're just sitting in the hotel room is
what you're doing or like that was my
bedroom at home okay I was watching it
and uh you know my family was opened and
it's a shame because I actually I'm very
fond of Jerry Jones actually love him
right I had the pleasure of meeting
Stephen Jones really like him and I know
the Dallas Cowboys are talented team and
I'm good friends with a really really
good friends with prime time Michael
Irvin guys like that so it's never the
Cowboys it's just a fans I really really
really despise Cowboys and unfortunately
you know when the Cowboys lose it's a
hard thing because you're going off and
join it if you mean but it's not really
about the Cowboys losing it's about the
centenary I think that Cowboys fans are
the most disgusting nauseating fanbase
in American history
I can't stand them no matter what they
do they can go one in 15 they can go
three and thirteen this season could end
on a January 3rd or something like that
at 7 o'clock and by 7:15 they're like
you know we're gonna win a Super Bowl
next year I mean I can't stand them I
really can't stand Cowboys so that's
where all of that comes from it's not
even about the team it's about their fan
base we've got the spot
so that's part Hollis Queens and then
your time in Philadelphia right with the
Enquirer and all that you just put it
all together it's mean growing up
surrounded by cowboy fans all my life
friends family members people like that
and it they're all the same they're all
the same they never take any moment to
smell themselves at all when they stink
and they spent up the place it doesn't
matter you know what they're gonna win a
Super Bowl next year rich trust me when
I tell you this talk to them they won't
even wait 15 20 minutes
I'm country they won't wait all day
everyone what a week nothing like that
in literally minutes later after a saree
season they'll still tell you they're
gonna win a Super Bowl that's why I
can't stay well what do you think is
ailing them in all seriousness right now
three and OH two three and three what do
you think the issue is right now Steven
coaching coaching coaching I mean I
think that when you look at their
defense from a talent perspective
they're they're obviously you know they
had a better year last year but with
Jada Smith and leave and direction even
Shawn Lee back there the bottom line is
that they've got a whole bunch of talent
injuries have derailed them to some
degree a couple of tackles on their
offensive line obviously you got to take
that into consideration last week of
Marvin Cooper guard Michael Gallup was
out the week before Randall Cobb was out
this week so injuries play a role but
there are coaches that have had less
talent that have had more success and at
some point in time you know you could
hold Jeremy Jones accountable but
primarily at this point it's to keeping
Jason Guerin in that position ten years
on the job three times he's made the
playoffs two playoff victories in ten
years and they call themselves America's
Team it's really unacceptable
the grand scheme of things in all
seriousness you know the only reason why
Jason Garrett still has this job as head
coach is because Jerry Jones clearly has
a personal affection point if he was
anyplace else outside of Cincinnati
because they did leave Marvin Lewis in
that position for 16 years without one
single playoff victory if it was anybody
else outside of Cincinnati Jason Garrett
would have been going by now but Jerry
Jones loves them and that's what the
situation yeah I'm so you don't buy it
the Jerry says this past week he said
that if if Jason Garrett was on the free
agent market he would have a gig right
away you don't think so well I don't
think so but I won't say he'll know it I
won't say it that emphatically because
Jason Garrett is an incredibly nice guy
by everybody that I know the venom I've
never had the pleasure of meeting him
everybody says that he's an incredibly
nice guy and you do have those guys that
just are they have that ability to
cultivate a relationship with those in
positions of influence and power where
you're inclined to give them a chance
simply because you like them but if
you're looking at this guy's record
there's no excuse for him to still be
the head coach of the Dallas Cowboys
look let's take for example Mike comma
in the Pittsburg my comment in
Pittsburgh his record is better than
everybody's outside of Bill Belichick
over the last decade or so and you know
folks were talking about how he needed
to go from last year they're damn sure
talking about how he needs to go down
and he's won nearly 65 percent of the
games he's been a numerous NFC AFC
rather AFC championship he's been to a
couple of Super Bowls he's won a Super
Bowl championship and has never had a
losing record in his career but they
talked about how did used to be changed
in Pittsburgh but in Dallas oh no such
thing because Jason Garrett is boys with
Jerry Jones that's what I find to be
said but I will applaud Jerry Jones for
the fact that he did not offer or allow
Jason Garrett to receive an extension on
that contract after last season he sat
up there said of Oklahoma players
accountable it's only right and fair
that I do the same when it comes to
Jason Garrett and I agree with that kind
of thinking right the one
only Stephen a Smith here on the Rich
Eisen show so who's the best team in the
NFL right now do you think it's a tough
call because on one hand the Patriots to
me have the top rated defense one would
argue we talked about the Patriots of
Chicago battle after that but now we've
got to pay attention to San Francisco
regardless of what Richard Sherman says
pulling a Michael Irvin keeping the same
intensity please don't lose this he's
the same advented that kind of but the
bottom line is San Francisco's only lamb
at twelve point eight points a game
their defense is incredibly stout you
got Richard Sherman and those boys in
the secondary you got Nick bowls and
those boys on the other on the offensive
line and they're going after the drafter
so they look impressive but I'm not sold
on them even though they've got the
number two Russian attack so we'll read
in those boys because I'm still not
totally Garoppolo he's the type that
won't necessarily beat himself but if he
that dude that can really take me over
the hump I'm not sure as of yet I would
look at New Orleans what they're doing
without Drew Brees four no undefeated
with Teddy Bridgewater for holding down
the fort
certainly not stellar offensively but
their defense has really stepped it up
just imagine what they're going to be
able to do if Drew Brees comes back it's
looking like we expect Drew Brees to
look I think a safe argument can be made
that New Orleans should be labeled as
the team to be although we can never
ignore New England so I just look at it
that way and we obviously can't ignore
Kansas City because of Patrick Mahone
and and I would tell you to keep your
eyes on Houston because the strong
Watson is emerging as a superstar in
this league and it's time that we show
him the respect he deserves
he beat the MVP in his own house last
week and we're gonna see again Thursday
Night Football tonight between the
Chiefs and the Broncos to kick things
off I would be remiss if I didn't use
some of my remaining time Stephen a
Smith with you about the fact the NBA
season will tip off in a week and the
games can't come fast enough for that
league right now right how much of a if
you will ding do you think or stain will
be left on the bronze legacy based on
his stance
daryl morey and what's going on with the
league in China Steven Naismith listen I
definitely think he's had the situation
at first things first he was wrong to
say that Daryl Morey was misinformed he
was not misinformed he was wrong to say
that there are more he was thinking
about himself instead of others because
clearly when you're talking about
standing for freedom and to support Hong
Kong he was not thinking about himself
now do I think it was wise for Daryl
Morey to send that tweet out no you're
an executive in the National Basketball
Association
for one of the storied franchises in
existence right now because we used in
rocket clearly our formidable than our
champion but they're clearly formidable
my problem with Daryl Morey was sending
that tweet at the time that he elected
to do so having said all of that still
at all LeBron James is somewhat sane
because he came across as focusing and
prioritizing dollars and cents as
opposed to human rights when it was
perfectly within his realm to sit up
there and say I'm a black man I'm an
American and I support human rights
civil rights and democracy everywhere
that's all he had to say he didn't have
to do anything more than that but he
should have at least done that so in
that regard I would tell you it's
somewhat of a stain on them but what I
would ask the public to think about is
who we're talking about here we're
talking about a person renowned for
being conscientious he's being of he's
been a conscientious observer he spoke
out on things and took in stance on
things and has tried to give a voice to
the voiceless about a plethora of things
and issues that have have really really
invaded our society by and large he's
been an incredible role model he's a
superstar that stepped out on the court
every night throughout his career and
has never cheated us with an effort his
commitment to excellence his condition
in the cetera et cetera
he's been philanthropic in so many ways
particularly with the schools and Akron
and other things that he has done he's
been a brilliant businessman as well and
we obviously knows he has business
interest in China so all of those things
should not you know his one remark or
myth hat in terms of speaking on the
issue of China and NBA
should not erase all the good that he
has done and then on top of it all I
would also like to
my folks is that regardless of how badly
we want these guys to resist at carbs
rich they're not statesmen you know
Condoleezza Rice and colon Powell have
had to speak on issues and Hillary
Rodham Clinton has had to speak on
issues it amazes me how we have
superstar athletes in their 30s who
never had a reason in hell to paint any
kind of attention or to speak on
geopolitical issues suddenly it's so
important for us to hear from them I
think as Intel it's incredibly unfair to
them particularly when Daryl Morey is
the one that gave it to me
and we haven't heard a word from him
since that time because he's obviously
been silenced by the NBA and in
particular Houston Rockets owner Owner
Tillman 42 so I would ask people to take
that into consideration
and try not to hold a broad James to
accountable or to responsible for not
Ella cuting words in the perfect fashion
that's not exactly his lane he needs to
know that for the future but we all need
to know that now in order to give him
the kind of break he deserves because
he's a superstar that has conducted
himself in pristine fashion throughout
his career and I think it's incredibly
unfortunate and sad that people are
ready to pounce on him over this issue
yeah I mean because I mean obviously
nobody's got a platform like him so if
he was going to use it for social issues
and civil rights issues here in the
United States a lot of folks thought he
should have done it for the world at
large and and so right and I understand
it but what I'm saying is that that's
where he needs to learn because again
regardless of what you feel like for
example when he has spoken out against
President Trump and others well again if
you're willing to step out and take a
stance on those issues right it's
entirely right for people to want to
hear from him on it I'm simply talking
about judging him for the imperfect
manner in which he articulated himself
he's not a wordsmith for example he's
you he's accustomed to speaking on
issues and he usually does so in
pristine fashion this was one of those
that he didn't write I mean and I was
one Gertie hear him say something on the
subject and holding the Chinese
government to account I also know a lot
of people in this town who told me that
if he did that the amount of money that
he could have lost from spacejam not
being shown in that in that world in the
tens of millions of dollars tens of
millions of them Stephen I mean it is a
very nuanced subject and very difficult
to say the least
well listen it's very difficult I think
that you would have handled it better I
would have ended it better but this is
what we do for a living you got to
remember that I mean you know when
people when we open our mouths we're
gonna we're gonna receive a stronger
level of culpability if we don't do it
in the right fashion because it's what
we do for a living that's not what he
does for a living he speaks on a
plethora of issues no doubt but in the
thing breath that's not what he does
every day and sometimes that level of
imperfection is gonna rip overhead and
it's going to show and now all I'm
saying is that give the guy a break and
give him a little bit of understanding
in that regard he had to take a
multitude of ditches not just with
himself but on a part of others into
account and he didn't handle it and I'd
be a fashion a matter of fact there were
some people that felt initially
Commissioner Adam Silver didn't handle
it
in ideal fashion yet somehow someway all
of these adults in the room who are far
more adroit and speaking and
articulating our behalf and articulating
thoughts on behalf of themselves into
entity they represent or held two lesser
degrees of accountability than a
basketball player and I don't know how
fair that is rich Steven McDo Steven a
Smith first take 10 a.m. to noon every
single day on ESPN one two three Eastern
on ESPN radio on the ESPN app for the
Stephen a Smith show Stephen a you're
the best thanks for coming on I just so
you know I had Michael Irvin on on
Tuesday I said I'm gonna have Stephen a
on Thursdays or anything you want me to
say to him and he was retort 'less he
admitted he has no retort right now
Stephen a well you know I mean don't
please be light on him - I mean shows up
on first cake you know that with that
toupee looking afro
and he had he got he got beat down
pretty good
it took him a few months to recover he
knows what time it is when he comes up
against me and I think that they had a
lot to do with why he had no rhetoric
take care of yourself Stephen a Smith
all right buddy thank you right back
catchin that Stephen a Smith at Stephen
a Smith on Twitter and Instagram right
here on the Rich Eisen Sheldon for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 under red TV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app